all right guys
bang bang yon's here what's up man
how's it going appreciate you having me
on of course
uh jan works at uh delphi digital
where i sit on the board which means
automatically he has to be smart
duh um but uh let's go through your
background first and uh then we can talk
about delphi and what you guys did there
yeah so after college i worked in
nutritional finance so
initially it was primarily equity
research where you're publishing
um reports on on a subset of coverage of
companies that you have under uh under
you and so
the idea is you're constantly trying to
produce actionable insights
understand where the the space is going
and
understand how the companies fit in
within the space and and as well as
a strong understanding of just financial
markets and um
financial modeling and kind of how that
all comes together and then from there
that was at bloomberg and then
afterwards i was
a deutsche bank where i was in uh
leveraged finance uh
crm and so the idea there is we're
loaning um providing debt to highly
leveraged companies and really
understanding
you know these are the riskiest
companies and realistically can they
actually pay this back and so
you kind of start to see really
ridiculous situations where
you're you know you're providing loans
and situations where you possibly
shouldn't be but there's
a lot of underlying relationships there
that kind of have to be respected and so
um that was kind of my my traditional
career and
we i fell down the crypto rabbit hole uh
i'd say
very beginning of 2017 i obviously heard
about bitcoin before and just kind of
didn't really put the time in to to
research it unfortunately
and then because it got into the space
in early 2017 just as
a casual investor and um just
as you know as most people tell you kind
of just fall down the rabbit hole and it
starts to take up more and more of your
time and
and um so i was working with uh three of
my colleagues bef uh
at the time this was anil uh medio and
kevin
and so we just noticed that we were
spending more and more of our time
trying to understand the space and on
one end you wanted to do it because
there were opportunities to make a lot
of money quickly and then
there's no better motivator than that
sometimes and so we
we really just spent all of our time on
this and um
after a while we actually really
appreciated what was going on and
thought that this had a lot of potential
and and we really wanted to be a part of
it professionally more than just
casual investors and so at that point we
started to think about how we could
enter the space professionally and so
some of the ways you think about working
with a specific project but that's tough
just because
you don't really at the time you know
you're learning so much in the space
so quickly that you know what you
thought you knew a few months ago is
totally different than what you do now
and so
we kind of started to realize that the
the space was iterating very quickly and
it didn't really make sense to commit to
one project but
we wanted to be abreast of everything
and really as involved as possible and
so
um from there we thought about what how
can we leverage our existing skill set
in the best way possible to kind of
monetize it and create a business out of
it and so we thought
the at the time the idea was
institutional money's going to move in
and so
everyone realized now that that process
happens a little bit a little bit more
slowly than expected and
and there are there are hurdles in the
way and so some of the hurdles are
custody
regulatory and you can kind of go down
the laundry list but
one of them was understanding how value
can accrue in the space why
i should invest like i need to be able
to read
an investment thesis that i can easily
digest and understand and then
bring to my border or to my cio and and
you know take it
to the next step and so we thought based
on what we were doing at the time based
on our interests we could
provide that caliber of research and
analysis
into this space and we didn't really see
it um
existing in any real credible way i
think you know some people were starting
to do it but
we thought there was a lot of a lot of
opportunity here and so
we started delphi in august of 2018
and we were kind of uh building behind
closed doors for a while trying to
figure out
um how we're really gonna build the
business what what was really necessary
and so
um we figured it would be a subscription
business and the idea was we would
provide
recurring research and uh that would be
one way to really scale the business is
over time
you'd build a subscriber base and and
that's kind of
how you build that business and part of
it was so we we bootstrapped the company
you know we
started we realized all right let's set
aside some money we know how much we
we haven't until you know we start
really running low on funds and so
we we sought out with that and realized
that you know the subscription model
takes some time to build up and
and we knew that going into it but one
of the ways we kind of
were able to almost bootstrap our own
liquidity issues was through our
consulting business and so
the consulting business initially
started as
funds came used us for due diligence and
so they would
almost treat us as an outsourced due
diligence team where they would say all
right we are interested in this sector
come back with investments from an
equity perspective from a token
perspective and why
and so those were larger one-ticket
items that
were great for providing capital to
business but
those the way that that business scales
is with price whereas the subscription
business scales
with users and so we needed both to kind
of happen in tandem and so we kind of
leveraged
the the consulting business to subsidize
the research and then we met you
i believe it was in in late 2018 um
and and through you and meeting tom at
51
and then we we merged with him at the
beginning of february and that was kind
of how
this relationship was born um since then
the company
has really grown we we've expanded just
recently we're up to
10 employees now so that that's it's
been great to see and i think the way
that it's kind of evolved has been
we've been able to iterate on the
recurring bit
a bit more in the sense that we
understand
what users want what they don't want and
at the same time the space
changes so quickly that we can't be very
rigid with our structure we have to be a
bit more nimble there
and then the consulting end what's
happened is
we had so initially our skill set was
understanding where to invest and then
from there
um through our research and just our
ability to look into as many tokens as
possible and really understand
why some are successful why they're not
and and kind of going from there
the consulting business evolved from
just looking into uh projects to invest
to actually designing the token
structures for
these projects and that's been that's
been great because we've been able to
really contribute to the space in in a
in a meaningful and tangible way and
and kind of re reuse as much of the ip
that we've built up
from the research side from the
consulting side to help design these
projects and then
just recently we announced that we were
having a ventures arm as well
and we thought that that was the next
natural process in our evolution to
um now we can not only we have the
research side but we can only
we can um design these tokens for
projects and also provide them with
capital assistance and actually
become you know a a real value provider
in the space beyond just
any kind of research or analysis and
then really helping projects and
investing and becoming more than just a
capital provider to the project but
actually
helping them with with design and and
dashboards and kind of
figuring out in what ways we can really
be a value add to them
and so what does delphi look like today
in terms of you've got the
research arm you've got the consulting
arm you've got the ventures what are the
products that are in that research arm
kind of what does
people come to you for consulting for
and then capital is pretty
self-explanatory
yeah so the research um we have on a
monthly basis we provide an in-depth
uh token report and the goal there is to
provide something as actionable as
possible for
clients um it's not always something
that we're
overly bullish on but there are
situations where we can be bearish
but we're not the way in which we are
typically bearish is not in the sense of
we're not going to tell you that a
project that everyone knows is bad is
bad and go into a lot of detail about it
that's just useless
so we'll kind of in those situations
we'll typically be a bit against the
grain
where we think that there's a
misunderstanding between
what people think is actually going to
happen relative to what is actually
happening and so
um again that's something that we think
is actionable but
so the research side we have those types
of reports
we have a lot more short form content we
realize that
we want to be high touch with our
clients but still maintaining
um a level of quality with the research
so
it's always like finding that balance
we're making sure we're not um
bombarding you with with too much but
that everything we are sending over
is has been filtered we have our
internal process that you know when a
report is done
we go through a system of checks to make
sure that everything is correct and and
obviously there are opinions where there
were there where it's not necessarily
going to be correct but it's opinion but
as long as it's fact-based and and the
assumptions are
are logical and so we have um
daily reports that we send out about uh
topics that we think are relevant
thematic reports where we'll dive into a
certain sector like defy or oracles and
things like that where
we'll break down the major players in
the space and kind of what they're doing
and oftentimes our ideas really stem
from those types of analyses where
we're looking at a sector and we see the
competitors and then we can quickly tell
which should succeed and then kind of
the reports evolve that way so
there the idea is to make all of the
research and
and the internal process processes as as
efficient as possible so if we're doing
research on something there's
more than just we can apply it to more
than just that report and so
that's kind of where the the consulting
and the venture arms come into play so
for consulting
we're we'll have um we'll help projects
that
are thinking about launching a token and
so we'll build out how they should
integrate it
what the distribution schedule should be
how each individual
user should function within the
ecosystem and that's kind of where we
think
our bread and butter really is is when
you think about these these token
structures
is understanding it's not just so if you
think about
what tokens were in 2017 they started as
a method of raising capital
and that's what they were it's an easy
way to get around regulations to raise a
bunch of money and
and which and you have no requirements
it's not equity that you're you're bound
by it's it's just free money
then as the as that period slowed down
it got to
all right well now we kind of have to
make these things have value somehow so
let's figure out how to tinker and
change some things to okay
to actually have the value accrue as the
project grows
and now we're at the phase where good
projects are
leveraging the token in a way that
allows them to
advance faster than they would have had
they not used the token
and so that's kind of where we really
come into play and what we've been
trying to help projects with as much as
possible it's
it's either bootstrapping adoption or
bootstrapping some kind of incentive
structure where
you can bring users to your platform and
reward them for being early and being
active
but in a way that can organic so
you have these rewards that are
basically token based and and the idea
is that over time
as those rewards kind of diminish the
natural functionality of the project
starts to take over and it's kind of the
same thing as as bitcoin you just do a
like a different level in the sense that
you have
the block rewards are a subsidy and over
time the fee market is supposed to
develop to offset the subsidy
and then that's how the the system can
operate organically and so
that's the same logic that we basically
apply to a lot of these um
projects that we help out with and then
what we've kind of had the luxury of
doing recently is now
certain projects that will help design
we can also invest and it's just
a really great way for us to become
you know one with the project at a
really early level
to to help them along the path and it
provides a great source of deal flow for
us and really understanding
you know if it's it's tough to think of
a situation where somebody can
understand an investment better than we
can
at the time because we're the ones who
designed it and so it's there's a lot of
a lot of benefit there that we kind of
are looking forward to using as well
makes a ton of sense um everyone wants
to know about d5
uh they see all kinds of crazy things on
twitter
uh you probably understand it better
than most what is defy
and what's happening over the last you
know 60 days in the d5 market
yeah now it's a great question so d5 is
basically
a way it's it's trying to replicate
services and financial markets
um without the intermediary that's
taking
the rent or or or or creating like some
some level of uh
it's it's like the centralized entity
that's removing transparency and so you
have these issues that
are kind of of the similar ethos as
bitcoin it's all
under that idea it's just more specific
more targeted and so what's great is
these aren't necessarily competing with
bitcoin you know
these aren't these d5 projects aren't
going to become stores of value
their value is a function of the amount
of fees and productive
value they can provide so what you're
starting to actually see
some kind of fundamental way to think
about these things and and d5 has has
been around for quite some time it's
just
it hasn't really taken off until
recently so and
it's it was it exists in 2018 2019
and and over time it's just become kind
of
more complex in terms of what people are
building so initially it was a lot of
borrowing and lending and so the idea
was i have this money i can
post as collateral and i take a
massively over collateralized loan and
now i have this capital they can do
things
with and if you think about like the the
smart contracts necessary to do
something like that they're a bit more
simple because
there's not a lot of interaction it's
the main interaction is provide
collateral withdrawal
other asset and now you're out of the
system so as
the development of of these systems has
kind of grown the use cases have evolved
with them and so
what we've seen recently um
was it was a combination of things so
you know after the the
large selloff in march everything kind
of bounced back
and that's when you really saw d5 start
to to blow up a lot
and it was a combination of things so on
one end you had
several d5 projects that were either
launching
um providing new products uh v2s
updates and and trying to basically
optimize their structure
and at the same time um and this side is
a bit more anecdotal where
um you had some institutions come into
the space that were basically
um almost suppressing bitcoin volatility
so they were they were coming in
and their whole goal was to provide
yields they were they were exercising
cover call strategies where they would
you know hold spot sell sell calls
and um they would just create a yield
that way and they were really
agnostic to the price of bitcoin but
more so just trying to generate a yield
and so
what that would do is that would flood
the market with a lot of calls and at
the same time
um you'd have some market neutral desks
or others that would
basically buy those calls on the cheap
and then sell spot to to kind of offset
that to create that hedge and and so
that kind of really dampened bitcoin
volatility where we saw bitcoin is
really flat from you know
uh end of april or like may until mid to
late june
and during that time we also saw
defy start to pick up and so it was a
really interesting combination of the
two where
now you're starting like bitcoin holders
are are you know
a lot of them trade leverage and use
options and so
when bitcoin is just bouncing between 92
and 96 and 97 for a month and a half
they they're losing their mind and so
at the same time they're seeing defy as
gaining 100
a week and a bunch of these assets and
so
their interests start to pour over as
well and so you started to see a lot
more um attention focus on the device
space because that's where the returns
were
and to an extent you can think of it
it's like there you know some people
think of it as
a bubble but realistically if you think
about the size
of d5 right now it's still less than a
ripple
or xrp and so like it's not a bubble in
the same way that we saw
2017 where everything was running and
and so you had like you know billions
and billions of artificial value created
here it's a very small set of of a
handful of names and that's why at the
same time
the amount of capital that flows into
them causes their price to even to move
up even even
further and so what's been useful is it
has brought a lot of attention to the
space
and created um a lot of a lot of
natural i guess demand and so what some
of these d5 projects are creating
are so it's it's intricate yield
generating uh mechanisms so you had
the whole liquidity mining um fiasco
that that will
you know only continue but but all like
continue to improve and so
initially liquidity mining is basically
i need you i want you to provide
liquidity for this project
and and or or basically post your assets
and and generate a yield and normally
the yield you'd get
was a function of how much people wanted
to borrow it but now
it's we supplement it with our token and
so the token
now you know users aren't getting
seventy percent they're getting fifteen
hundred percent or a thousand percent
yield on their assets and so
that doesn't happen how does that happen
that i think that's what people are
confused by right
they hear a thousand percent yield on
something and they're like
this has got to be a scam right so like
explain how
like something like that happens and and
then we talk about like yield farming
and all that
yeah absolutely so it's it's that value
is annualized
and the reason it ends up ballooning is
you'll have these projects that
they'll let's just say they have a
thousand tokens they'll only distribute
you know a small amount at first and
it's kind of like a leaking faucet where
they'll distribute that gradually
and what happens is um as those tokens
get
get um distributed the the idea is at
the same time they're looking to
uh incorporate ways that those tokens
will have value in the future
and so part of those is a function of
governance and then
within governance you can um structure
it's such that a certain amount of the
fees from the entire protocol go to
those tokens so
the way what happens is they start to
issue a few tokens but those tokens
start to balloon
in price and their schedule is still to
distribute
one token a day you know but just as a
scale
but that token initially started at 30
cents and now it's at
40 bucks and so the yield has just gone
insane and like your the capital you're
providing is still the same and so what
happens is
a lot of money floods into there because
you know these markets want to normalize
that yield and say i'm going to take it
and eventually they kind of come down
but
for extended periods for weeks at a time
you know there's people farming with
like four-digit yield which is absurd
and and obviously it's not going to be
sustainable forever but
the idea there in the long run is that
so the fear is and and kind of the the
way you can differentiate
some good from some bad projects with
yield farming is okay
once that yield farming stops how what
portion of these assets will actually
remain with that project
and how many will just you know
opportunistically jump to the next
situation
where there's the most heel farming and
it almost makes it tough because
projects won't
all debut at the same time so even if
your project where you have a natural
amount of yield that you can
generate the problem is if somebody else
launches after you
that can then just provide that yield
it's like even if i like what i'm
getting here and
you know holding all else constant your
project will generate me a higher yield
it still makes sense for me to move my
assets somewhere else and capture that
and then eventually move back
and so that's kind of where the the
yield farming craze is happening
but um it's it's just understanding yeah
which projects will do the best job of
retaining that capital
and then at the same time how can they
leverage that capital to
um generate actual fees so not fees that
are
inflated by the they're just issuance of
the token but from
providing a product that's actually
useful and so that's where
things kind of get interesting and and
really seeing how this whole
um space will shake out so my two
questions are like
one how sustainable are some of these
organizations and then two
how many are there right i keep hearing
people talk about like how much value is
locked in d5
and then and i go look and i literally
can't find how many
actual d5 projects there are there seems
to be like more and more coming online
every day
and so is this a function of where
there's like one or two big ones and
then there's
so many small ones that have a little
bit of value locked up but when you kind
of
uh count it all up and total it it ends
up being a big number
or is this something where there's maybe
10 you know kind of winners or leaders
in the space
and then everything else doesn't matter
like how do you think about the market
structure
both in terms of sustainability and then
also in just the aggregate number of
things that actually are going on
yeah sustainability is definitely an
interesting one um
i i think some will have slightly more
sustainable models
so the good thing is a lot of these
projects are also
at the i guess cutting edge of of token
econ and token structures and they're
also really looking to
constantly improve them through a very
public governance process
as well as outsourcing some of that to
teams like us where we'll we'll try and
help in any way we can
and so um
the sustainability is tough i i
definitely think
there there is a large level of
sustainability because there's
there's the demand to borrow and the
demand to to to find
ways of of figuring out the most
efficient yield and what like some of
these projects will really do is you
provide assets and then
they can search the market for basically
all other yield providing products and
optimize there and so
like you'll i think you'll have a
situation where the smartest and and the
kind of the best ones win
a lot of them work in in tandem and
it's actually funny so the idea is with
some of these you can
effectively so let's say i want to take
my assets and i place them into this
pool
to provide liquidity the way that
the value of your your share of the pool
is now a token technically so
if i put a hundred dollars like just
thinking about it easily if i put a
hundred dollars into this thousand
dollar pool
um and now there's a thousand bucks so
i'm technically ten percent we'll just
say
each token represents um a hundred bucks
so there's ten tokens issued
and the idea is my token represents ten
percent of the pool
the pool grows as it accrues fees
and so now like this asset that i have
which represents my ownership in the
pool
is also valuable then i can take that
asset and
basically park it somewhere else and you
kind of get these these these
uh interesting loops where that's where
people can really start to blow up yo
because you can
keep earning yield on the assets that
you're borrowing against and
and so it's it's an interesting loop um
the one of the more interesting things
to see is is a lot of these projects
were kind of
developed in silo in the sense that we
understand what our risks are as a
project we will develop these mechanisms
to institute balances in there but
the problem is they can't account for
new products that come out and
and create sources of demand and supply
that completely throw their systems out
of whack and and makers one of those
where
they're having a bit of trouble where
they have there's
because of another yield farming project
that's rewarding you based on the amount
of assets you provide
basically a lot of dye gets stuck in
compound but
so it creates demand for dye that that
isn't really programmed in
and then sorry the other question was um
in terms of just like the aggregate
number of these
is this like a winner take most and
there's two or three winners
um or is there literally you know over a
thousand d5 projects and each one has a
little bit of
capital or assets in it and that leads
to this big define number that everyone
uh continues to kind of point to no it's
definitely more of the former
where you have a lot of these larger
projects that are
consuming a lot of the liquidity
themselves and
if they can differentiate enough there
there is a world where they can all kind
of co-exist
and so um what's good is they are
iterating quickly and trying to figure
out new ways to both
incentivize users and efficiently use
that capital but
what the whole space is effectively
doing is is basically trying to
replace exposures that or replace
products that exist in
traditional finance and you know it
started with lending and borrowing and
now it's the ability to kind of
invest in synthetic assets that
represent a certain exposure so you
could effectively
own an apple own apple stock exposure
through using d5
but with an oracle that's pegged to um
the certain amount of assets and so
that's kind of where the space begins to
evolve and
um part of the way that some of these
projects
really uh benefit is if they can provide
if and if they can suck up enough
liquidity then you
as a trader as a user you can buy like
trade in and out of assets through these
projects rather than
through a centralized exchange and so
the idea is centralized exchanges make a
lot of money and they make it on that
fee
so if you can now instead transfer the
fee to the user providing the liquidity
and then and i as the user as the trader
can
don't have to deal with any kyc i don't
have to register my account i don't have
to
um store my assets with an exchange i
can trade from my wallet effectively
and assets never leave my custody and
and so
that's where you're kind of connecting
two markets where one you have
individuals with assets that
are effectively idle and and they can't
do anything with them
with traders that want to buy in and out
of out of positions but
don't want to trust their assets to an
exchange or
or um register for kyc and and the
difference is
it needs to get to the point where it's
competitive enough where
all right if if i'm still getting way
better execution on exchange i'm just
going to use that but
as that kind of gradually there's like i
guess a tipping point where
over time execution will kind of expand
and really get better on the
decentralized side and that's where
i think you'll continue to start to see
continue to see a lot of growth
and so as part of this like when the
value gets locked how much of that is
net capital inflow versus uh it's kind
of this
synthetic uh asset that got created in
the ecosystem right
and an example would just be um kind of
is the interest
uh compounding on itself from people who
are already interested in d5
or is there a a pretty significant net
capital inflow
into the space and that's what's leading
to a growing
kind of value locked and defined number
yeah no it's it's definitely
the uh the capital flowing into the
space um
and so the the question becomes less so
is it is it that but
but to what extent can incentives
sustain that growth and and so that's
where the the question is
can we continue to figure out ways to
incentivize additional users to bring
capital to the space
and so far you know it's been going well
and and um
projects are getting very creative with
how they think about
the long-term uh sustainability of these
models because you do have to initially
reward users
more than they would normally receive
for bringing their capital here and the
goal is
to retain them as long as possible but
um
it's it's not so much like they're on
the synthetic asset side the idea there
is that a lot of them are are backed
with real assets
and so if i i'm basically like it's the
idea here basically synthetics where
their platform
allows users so i the two users that
exist
are the collateral providers and the
traders so i as a collateral provider
can post my collateral of assets into
into
into their product with then they use
snx tokens and the idea there is
as a user um i can
buy so on one if i'm providing the
capital i need to
receive something in return to to do
that and so
they receive a fee and where is this fee
coming from it's coming from traders and
so
you have this massive pool of assets
that is is uh seven and a half times
over collateralized but the idea there
is
so these assets sit as the backstop and
you can issue
synthetic products against them so if
you have 750
dollars worth of assets locked you can
create a hundred dollars worth of
synthetic assets
whatever that asset is it can it can be
basically anything all you need is an
oracle to price it
and so now somebody can come in and buy
synthetic exposure
to basically any asset that they can
price and and kind of have economic
exposure to something that
if they're living in another country
they wouldn't really be able to buy
apple stock or anything like that and so
there's there's a lot of value on the
synthetic side but they're not as much
where they're kind of created out of
thin air there's
it's it's it's what was probably the the
biggest
hurdle for defy initially where because
you can't take credit risk against
anyone you everything has to be over
collateralized
and that kind of created a bit of a
choke point but as
you create enough uses for the assets
that
are borrowed against them um it it still
makes
overclockwise these positions a
worthwhile um uh
i guess endeavor for the individuals
providing that collateral
makes sense and what's the impact on
bitcoin and uh ether while this is going
on
yeah so what's interesting is um you
know um
defy has ran from um
april may june and still into july and
and what you started to see was
ethereum kind of wake up first at the
end of june
and what was the initial thing was um
if you look at the amount of gas spent
so a lot of these d5 projects are built
on
on ethereum and the idea there is they
can design these mechanisms in
any any way they want and they borrow
the security of ethereum and and
by that if like the only way to really
hack these projects from like a 51
type level is to actually control the
ethereum network which is
really difficult to do so um what
happens is
a lot as these projects are growing um
gas
you see every time you interact with
these contracts um you have to pay a gas
and gas is a function of two costs
one is the price of gas which is just
based on the supply and demand at the
time and then the other is the quantity
of gas
and that's the function of the
complexity of the contract
so a lot of these contracts are pretty
complex and
um when people were yield farming you'd
have to pay you know sometimes 50 bucks
for a transaction
and the thing is you're getting so much
yield that you didn't care
so everyone was just happily paying
these huge gas prices
and that started to kind of really kick
off the demand for
eth and i think
it had enough of an effect to start
moving price up like that demand for gas
because it was
almost you know 50 of issuance in terms
of you know trying to think about like
how to how to um
proportion personalize like that the
amount of gas um so definitely had
somewhat of an impact on the price
and then the narrative kind of started
coming about that if you know d5 really
thrives and eats has to thrive as well
which i agree with to an extent i still
think these
d5 projects gain a lot more um on their
own than than eve kind of does but
but eth by nature should kind of
appreciate as well and so
you start to see um eat started to
really trend up first and then right
afterwards bitcoin came
and at the same time we had spot volume
really pick up and and
and that's when um things started to
really take off and as soon as that
happened
all of d5 quickly pulled back and so you
you started to see
where you know some projects were
slightly less sticky
they had some pullback some projects
that were
weren't fully developed yet they had big
pullback and whereas some of the
projects that
were a bit more ingrained had actual use
cases at the time
definitely pulled back but just not as
much and and the pullback was natural as
you saw you know the bitcoin traders fly
in
the same way they come out and so what's
interesting and these cycles have
happened over time where
alts really do well when bitcoin's
volatility is at all-time lows and and
that's just because of boredom and
and search for returns basically
and so i don't think we've had a time
though where
there have been this many alts that
actually had real fundamental value or
or actual cash flows associated with
them so
we did see you know bitcoin take off
alts pull back
but we they didn't really fall as much
as they normally would
relative to kind of previous scenarios
and so
we've we actually started to see some of
the ones that have
adoption and some um use case grow
i think that you know bitcoin and d5 can
grow in tandem because in in reality d5
is so small compared to bitcoin it
really doesn't matter as much
and then if you think about you know the
metrics for bitcoin a lot of the ones we
like to look at
are aside from the normal ones just um
looking at the distribution of of the
the
holder base and kind of like what the
characteristics of of supply and demand
really are right now and so you're
seeing you know the the amount of
bitcoin that's moved in the past year
being at all-time lows so that's you
know a lot of bitcoin that's just
sitting idle
um one of the ways we like to look at um
the level of weak hands is
so if you track volatility of bitcoin
relative
to the amount of the to the percentage
of
its supply that's moved in the past
three months and so the idea is
if uh what you'd see before was when
there was a big spike in volatility
whether it was up or down
you would see a spike in the percentage
of supply that's moving the past three
months and that just means
you know more people are are reacting to
the price change and what we've seen
with each subsequent
spike is that the amount the increase in
uh three months in the supply that's
moving less than three months has
declined
so people are basically ignoring the
spikes as much and then they're just
sitting on their bitcoin
at the same time you're seeing you know
basically near one-year lows of
bitcoin on exchanges which is which is
really great to see because you know the
only reason you'd really move it there
is to
trade and some other interesting ones
are
you can track um basically the amount of
whales that exist
and so if you you track that over time
you can really see how
whales accumulate so basically a whale
being an entity that holds at least a
thousand bitcoin
and so you'll see the quantity of those
guys
increase as price really falls off and
then decrease
as as price uh picks up as they're kind
of cashing out basically
and it's it's another way of just
looking at like smart money basically
and what you've seen right now is that
number keeps growing in the sense that
the quantity of wales
has continued to pick up and so
realistically that's what you
want to see if you think about like the
most bullish case for bitcoin
you'd want price running right now on
the least amount of outside demand
possible because that just means that
that has yet to be satisfied and so
i think that's what we're really seeing
where the existing user base is
really dug in people are trading bits
here and they're
trying to scalp more but there's not
that much
that's people are are kind of numb to
price changes and they're just waiting
for the next leg up i think um
and so i think we're at a situation
where the amount of new demand really
needed to move
price up is at or near like all-time
lows
and and so i think you know combining
that with the macro environment the the
fact that you're seeing
institutional investors warm up to it
and like the whole idea of um
the the reduced career risk associated
with it and all those ideas um
yeah i think it i think bitcoin
uh d5 affects bitcoin on on micro time
frames
but on a larger time scale bitcoin's
just so much bigger that i think
both can can definitely do well and and
the idea with d5 is that
as people get into bitcoin if even a
small subset of them kind of
make their way down the uh the rabbit
hole um
that can be a huge boon for that space
so all these people keep tweeting at me
all season
when alt season sir uh that's basically
what you're talking about here
what is likely to happen kind of how do
you look at that
yeah um no it's uh it's a good question
so i think
each time we'll see bitcoin run up it's
it's fair to assume alts will pull back
in terms of like sats and and so part of
part of the reason that exists is a lot
of these pairs only really true like
now that they trade on versus like so a
lot of these bigger alls they trade
versus a dollar and versus
um bitcoin and so when they trade versus
bitcoin as bitcoin moved up
they would it would be less likely that
let me
rephrase that so as with
now they have a dollar pair and there's
a lot of volume there
they can be more appropriately priced in
the dollar so when
bitcoin runs up they don't necessarily
have to pull back as much because
they can sit flat versus the dollar
they'll decline versus bitcoin but you
don't really see
a massive decline there to the same
extent i still think
um alts really need bitcoin to be quiet
for some time to to do well
i think um certain catalysts for
individual projects can be
strong enough to offset a strong bitcoin
move but
um in in the end an aggregate alts kind
of need
really muted volatility out of bitcoin
to
to get enough um to get people
comfortable enough
and bored enough to start dabbling in
them again
and and so yeah and so if bitcoin
rips you know between now and the end of
2021 like i think a lot of people
including myself think uh does that
positive or negative for the halts um
i think for the majority of them it'll
probably be negative but
i and that's uh i think because of the
fact that a lot of them don't really
have any fundamental value
and that's fair i think with d5 the
reason it
has some is because there's immediate
product market fit where you're just
enabling speculation you're enabling
borrowing lending and like
that's pretty much the biggest use case
for crypto right now is speculation and
so
if you can enable that with a project in
a unique way
then you do have a media product market
fit and so that's kind of you know what
we also look for is
is understanding which projects um don't
require
the crypto user base to expand massively
in order to be successful
and and so that i think that removes a
lot of execution risk from our
investment strategy
and helps us on that front but
i think you know a lot of vaults that
that
don't have reason material adoption
where
the the use case doesn't really um
justify the current price
will definitely suffer you know with
with massive bitcoin upside but
uh what you'll end up seeing is
basically the alts
bitcoin will rip also kind of stay flat
or come down a little bit against
they'll say flatish against the dollar
come down a little bit in
income down in terms of sats and then
bitcoin pauses and then money floods
back in and the idea there being that
bitcoin pulling back you know one
percent means that alts can really
because that's a lot of capital leaving
bitcoin flooding into alts and not that
much
is required to make these alts move up
and so you'll still basically kind of
start to see people
performing that trade to an extent but i
think with d fights a little different
where
now that there is some actual cash flow
associated with these projects
it's not as momentum driven and there's
more fundamentals associated with it
and so what is like how does this play
into the token economics
and the value of cruel work that you
guys do right so people come to you and
they basically say hey
i want help with this stuff um i think
that
bitcoin is well understood kind of off
on its own and
strong and not really going to change at
all
when these other people come to you and
they say hey we want help with the token
economics for the value of cruel like
what do
you guys spend time talking to them
about how do you actually construct that
and maybe give me an example or
something yeah so
it um it can really vary
um if if it's a live project it's
uh you're you're a little bit more boxed
in depending on
kind of how far along they are and
what's going on there but
um with with a completely new project
you you kind of have you know a clean
slate to work with and the idea
that the thought process we go with is
you need to understand
exactly all the users in your ecosystem
um what their individual incentives are
and then
what is needed to bring additional users
to the system and so
we just kind of think about it on a
micro level in terms of
what are the individual how are these
individual users going to act
based on what is rational for them and
so
um i think one that we designed from
we actually uh it was originally
consolidating engagement with axi
infinity it's a gaming project and then
um over time
so we initially kind of designed the
token to work with them on that and then
they were launching we had the ability
you know the timing worked out were we
also able to invest and uh so in in this
situation
basically the game already exists they
have a user base and
in in layman's terms of games it's you
can think of it as as as pokemon
that are battling each other but the the
monsters you have themselves
are nfts so um non-fungible tokens that
you own
so you can buy and sell these these
creatures you can breed them
and and they all have a lot of
characteristics um have a lot of
advantages disadvantages and so there's
a lot of strategy involved and the idea
there is it's not
insanely complicated from a smart
contract perspective because
the game itself doesn't need doesn't run
on smart contracts when you and i battle
it doesn't
it doesn't have to register to the
blockchain it's only when we update
stats or or buy and sell these nfts that
that they hit the blockchain so
from that perspective it's not as
dependent on that
what we basically designed was a token
that the goal was all right how do we
reward existing users keep them sticky
but also
provide a lot of incentives for new
users to come into play and so
um on one end we structured we added a
token aspect that
basically rewards new users for playing
if you play a certain amount of games
a week you you receive a certain amount
of tokens the other reward is if you
play a certain amount of games
and you stake the tokens you can receive
a certain amount
of rewards from this centralized pool of
assets
all in-game spend goes so if if you and
i
if i if i buy something from you and
a certain percentage of that just goes
into this pool so none of the value
accrues to the company
every time there's in-game spend you
want to buy an item want to do anything
it goes to this pool and the idea is you
can leverage this pool
and and so what we've been doing is this
this
this pool will will eventually be a dow
that the token holders can govern
but the idea is if you're you're much
more likely to spend
a couple hundred dollars in this game
knowing i can just sell these later on
and and recoup like potentially more
of more than i paid just because you
know the expansion of the game relative
to a game like fortnight where i paid 50
bucks on some aesthetic gear and it's
stuck and so
the the fluidity of that value i think
enables a lot more in-game spend because
it's not a sunk cost
and what we're trying to do is is
further encourage that
with the idea that the fees aren't going
to
the company so now it's all going into
this pool
with the goal of redistributing it to
users based on incentives and
how can we leverage this pool to to to
create
uh to basically grow the game and so
within the pool there was a lot of you
know individual um
dynamics where we built in a score that
you'd get for holding certain tokens and
then the score would enter you into a
lottery that you can win a prize and
and so you kind of create a lot of these
supply syncs
that um that actually provide
value to the users in the same time so
the only way you can get access to these
individual prizes by buying and staking
tokens the only way you can get these
tokens are
by playing or by buying them in the open
market and so like there's there's a lot
of value in in having these tokens and
it kind of makes you part of the game
and kind of
um distributes the value to the users
and and
encourages them to actually participate
to figure out how to
leverage this pool to to drive more
users and so
it's one of these situations where uh
decentralization
isn't is it's definitely a spectrum and
i think the further out you go the
harder it gets
especially to kind of to to to direct
a ship and so with with this structure
the centralized aspect is still the game
maker and and they're building all these
products and then you want them
incentivized
because they need to keep expanding with
the game but at the same time the value
accrual and and where all the capital
flows
goes to everyone and so these kind of
structures that that
can be um sustainable for a long period
of time and then the goal is
you know we'll have those rewards
that'll last for years but over time
the the rewards should be a function of
just redistribution from the pool to new
users and that way
the kind of game the game keeps
expanding and and that was the incentive
uh
instead of model we kind of built there
and one other one that i want to talk
about because uh
pretty much everyone at delphi won't
leave me alone about it
my partner jason literally texts me like
once a week about it
is uh thor chain and roon
right i think are the two names yeah
what the what the hell is this
so thor chain is the name rune is the
token um
so the idea there is who came did you
guys come up with the name or do they no
no the the team is big fans of norse
mythology and so uh
you you understand how ridiculous it
sounds when jason is texting me thor
chain and i'm
i can't tell if he's joking or not but
all right go ahead what is this no we
we mentioned them like oh we love the
project have you ever thought about
potentially changing the name because
you you know the the the first step of
every discussion we have with anyone
about this project right it's it's
and so um the idea there is
so liquidity pools are so uniswap is a
liquidity pool and others exist now
where the idea is you know in layman's
terms it's two assets
and the pools is fifty percent of one
asset fifty percent of another
and if i want to buy asset a i can
i sell asset b receive asset a and
the the execution i get is a function of
the size of these pools
so as more people add assets to these
pools i can trade in and out of those
two pairs
with less slippage and in return i pay a
fee
and the fee accrues to the pool so the
users who provide their liquidity get a
fee
and so this isn't the idea of you have
idle assets now you can generate some
kind of a yield on them
by providing a service to somebody else
and this is kind of how you you move out
of the the centralized exchange space
um uniswap was primarily focused on
ethereum whereas
the idea with door chain is
all right so even taking a step back one
of the bigger issues with with
defy and bitcoin is it's very hard to
bring
native bitcoin to defy because native
bitcoin exists on its own blockchain
and with defy you either there's rap
situations where somebody now has
custody of the original bitcoin and you
have like a rap bitcoin and the whole
idea with
rap bitcoin or all these like um
comparisons are
that you wrap it in something that makes
it erc20 compa
like erc20 assets so it's much more
compatible with the within the ethereum
ecosystem
and it still has the same um economic
representation of an original bitcoin
um but the idea there then you have to
create an incentive structure for the
people that are protecting
the the original portion and so it adds
a layer of fees
what thor chain is trying to do is all
assets will effectively stay on their
native chains
um what they are they what happens is
they go into wallets
that are controlled by nodes and so
these nodes
are run by users who hold roon token
and you have to stake a certain amount
of this token and
in return you operate a node and you're
basically what's securing the assets in
these products
and then for the individuals want to
provide liquidity now
i can take my asset so whether it be
bitcoin
and i can place it in this liquidity
pool i it's still native bitcoin
and in return i can generate a yield on
these products
the one of the unique things that they
do i guess is so each each pool
is is roon and rune and whatever other
asset
and what what helps there is since the
liquidity is a function of the size of
the pool if you fractionalize the pools
into a lot of smaller pairs
you hurt like so if you had you know if
there were
if eath was in a few different pools i
would get
worse execution on that eath relative to
it just being in one large pool and so
by by establishing a common asset that's
in every pool which is roon like if i
wanted to trade bitcoin for eth
basically i take my bitcoin and sell it
what it goes into the bitcoin room pool
and then
roon cells into the other room pool for
ethereum and like
out comes eth and the idea that the the
way that they're kind of building that
is
now also you have a lot of individuals a
lot of idle assets and now i can
actually generate a yield on them that i
wouldn't really be able to do elsewhere
and the way that the token comes into
play is it's
it's used to secure the platform um it's
used as the
counter part to every um liquidity pool
and at the same time they have a subset
of it that's that's set aside
for issuance basically to reward users
for placing their assets in the pool so
the way that this this project actually
works is you need enough liquidity if
you put into these pools
so that the execution becomes comparable
but
it's tough for people to provide
liquidity initially because if no one's
trading on it then i don't really want
to provide the query because i'm not
going to get any fees
so that that's like the kind of the boot
traffic mechanism where okay if you
provide liquidity
we'll pay you an extra tokens and so now
everyone's going to kind of come in
and flood and place their assets into
these pools because they can earn
yield on otherwise idle assets which
would ideally
create enough um depth where
transactions can actually be competitive
with other venues
and then as you bring in more users then
the fees kind of go up because they just
accrue as a function of volume
and and then more users kind of bring in
and that's kind of the positive
reflexivity that that they're hoping to
achieve
i must stick with my bitcoin but at
least i understand it now they'll blame
you
and and look i think you know before we
go to finish up like
a lot of what's happening in d5 and with
the token economics and a lot
and a lot of this stuff is trying to
recreate you said at the beginning right
like recreate what already happens in
the legacy finance world
but do it without a centralized
authority uh with more transparency with
more automation
right with a different kind of ownership
structure and so this is really just
kind of recreating things that already
exist
but just in a new kind of souped-up you
know
improved digital version right yeah
and the value accruing to users that are
providing the other end of the of the
product versus the
central identity that's just that's a
company basically
yeah i mean like you know from a high
level just like that as a thesis like
that makes a lot of sense
i think the big question is you know
obviously which ones are going to be
successful first
what's the timing you know what do the
legacy players do in response
like there's so many moving parts here
but i think just at a high level that
thesis of like
hey there's uh kind of like analog or
very bureaucratic and centralized
existing examples in legacy finance
system they're super profitable
businesses that are very powerful uh if
you can disrupt them with decentralized
digital versions of their own business
and help the market participants accrue
value like that should be a valuable
thing and people would want to use it
and you know so i think it generally
makes sense
yeah yeah and the idea is you you you
have some existing users that already
want to speculate and kind of
participate and
it it achieves product market fit a lot
easier so it's just kind of that that
whole reduction of execution risk
in terms of an investment yeah it makes
sense um i asked same two questions to
wrap up
favorite book or most important book
what is it
oh
most important book that's tough
let me think about that and uh what's
the other one
aliens believer or non-believer
definitely a believer
why i think there's just uh especially
this year i mean if it wasn't for kobe
there's so much evidence that's kind of
come out and and
been uh swept under the rug that's uh
that's that's um been huge for us like
i i think if yeah if coco wasn't around
people would be losing their mind but
there's just too much other [ __ ] going
on that
people don't even realize that there's
videos waiting for trump to drop in an
interview by accident
like just be like oh yeah they only oh i
mean like
just literally accidentally dropped the
fact that there's aliens like he
i feel like he's the president if
anyone's gonna accidentally let that
information out of tim
yeah or through a tweet when he's on
ambien or something accidentally yeah
he literally might just tweet and say
confirm the video and just leak it
himself
right like something crazy all right
what book you got for us
and then yeah book um just because it is
very timely now
um so a neil uh ceo
has been uh and kev they both read is a
book called traction
and uh they've used that to really kind
of help shape how
the company has been developing and i
think you know they
they really read it about like two or
three months ago and um
we've definitely been making a lot of
internal changes just to optimize and
really
like create efficient processes and and
really build the company in a way that's
that's scalable and making sure that
everyone kind of is directionally
aware of what we want to do and so i
think yeah that's probably the most
important book for us right now
if i depict i never heard of that one
i'm not to read that uh you could ask me
one question what you got for me
um who's been your
least favorite part no no uh
uh who do you think you've learned the
most from what what guest do you think
you learned the most from
that would have been an epic question i
don't want to put you on the spot there
i don't even know who i have to actually
think about that um whoever i learned
the most
i can't pick one person uh people off
the top of my head
um you know there's all like the the
well-known people that everyone would
assume
like the you know the chamas the raul
paul's the cat coles
all those types of people um i think
that uh somebody who was
uh really interesting uh
was ben mesrick uh so he wrote bitcoin
billionaires he also did
um social network movie
and he's written like 25 books or
something he wrote a book about aliens
like all kinds of stuff
uh but he was fascinating to talk to
because he basically just flipped the
publishing world on its head so what he
does is he basically writes a
manuscript he then goes sells the book
right or sells the movie rights unless
the movie rights are bought
then he writes the actual book so he
goes like complete reverse
um and then he also was like super
uh forthcoming and transparent about
like what he got right and wrong in the
social network
and that whole story and then why he did
the bitcoin billionaire book and
i don't know he was just like the most
like or one of the most fascinating
people i think
that i've had on which is probably not
the one that people would assume for me
to pick
yeah it's really interesting i'll
definitely check that one out yeah he's
great
um all right where can people find you
where can they find out more about
delphi
yeah so our website is www.delphi
digital.io
and you can find me on twitter at john
lieberman
delphi digital dot io who whose idea was
it use the io
well dot com was taking the time we're
actually in conversations trying to buy
it
somebody had it from a while back you
can't tell people that jason calcandis
is the one who told me this he goes no
dude i never talk about urls i'm trying
to buy on the podcast because everyone's
going to go and bid it up
we can uh delete that yeah we'll just
cut that part out
guys all right man listen thank you so
much for doing this i'll do it again in
the future
yeah thank you really appreciate your
time it was a pleasure